i have been searching for you mr ward  you are the seventh son of a seventh son  an order of noble knights combating the  forces of darkness  the books explore some really wonderful  interesting themes in terms of destiny  and  in terms of the good and evil inside of  everyone  i can't wait to see this movie in imax  that's how i want to see it one of the  things about the tone of this movie is  that it is big it's big it's  fantasy it's big feelings big mythology  we've done everything we can to make it  sort of visually impactful as it can be  it really  immerses you in the experience when  something is that  huge you're able to kind of enter into  the world and into the  outrageous size of these feelings too  the imax experience only adds to that  and and  gives it um it amplifies it all join us  you